So why do we want to measure the traffic
on the network? One reason might be billing. So
for example, we might want to charge a customer
based on how much traffic they've sent on a network.
In order to do so, we need to passively
measure how much traffic that customer is sending. Here's
an example of measurements of inbound and outbound traffic
volumes. On a link on the Georgia Tech campus network.
The Y axis is shown in bits per second, and the X axis is the time of
day. Now, a user might be billed based on how much traffic they send on the
network. A common mode of billing is called
95th percentile billing, where a customer pays for
what's called a committed information rate, or CIR,
and throughput is measured every five minutes. The customer,
then, may be billed on the 95th percentile,
of these five minute samples. So if we were
to bill on the 95th percentile of inbound traffic,
we might approximate that 95th percentile by the orange
line I've drawn on here. And the customer
might be billed at this rate, even though they're
allowed to sometimes burst at higher rates. Another common
reason to measure is security. For example, network operators
may want to know the type of traffic that's
being sent on the network so they can detect
rogue behaviour, and network operator may want to measure
traffic on the network to detect compromised hosts or
the presence of Botnets or Denial of Sevice attacks,
two phenomena that we'll talk about later on in
the course. For the rest of this lesson, since
we focused a lot on performance measurement already, I will
mainly focus on passive traffic data measurement.